[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Siri schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen wie jeden Sonntag eine kürzere 19
Uhr Ausgabe Christian Otto benimmt
später den sportlichen nackig gebündelt
guten Abend hier sind unsere Themen
Trauer in Südkorea bei einer Massenpanik
in Soul sterben mehr als 150 Menschen
viele werden verletzt
Streit ums Bürgergeld die CDU droht mit
einer Blockade im Bundesrat und fordert
Nachbesserungen
und Stichwahl ums Präsidentenamt bleibt
in Brasilien der Rechtspopulist
bolsonaro im Amt oder macht seinen
linker Herausforderer Lula das Rennen
[Musik]
nach der tödlichen Massenpanik in
Südkorea kündigte Präsident June
Staatstrauer an es waren tragische und
dramatische Szenen die sich gestern
während einer riesigen Halloween-Party
ereigneten mehr als 150 vor allem junge
Menschen sind dabei im dichten Gedränge
ums Leben gekommen
das Unglück geeignete sich in Soul der
Hauptstadt Südkoreas mitten im Zentrum
liegt das auch bei ausländischen
Besuchern beliebte ausgeviertel ita
Yvonne dort abseits der Hauptstraßen
gibt es sehr enge Gassen mit Restaurants
Bars und Tanzclubs in eine dieser
Nebenstraßen strömten plötzlich von
beiden Seiten Menschenmassen für all
jene mittendrin gab es kein Entkommen
Miriam Steiner
in einem Gemeindezentrum in Soul suchen
Sie immer noch nach ihren Freunden und
Familienangehörigen
dieser Australier war gestern mit drei
Freunden unterwegs zwei sind im
Krankenhaus einer Tod
das waren so viele Leute junge Leute ich
musste mich umdrehen und sagte der Menge
ihr könnt hier nicht lang hier sterben
Menschen
so sah es vorher aus mehr als 100.000
Leute waren in dem beliebten
Ausgehviertel in der südkoreanischen
Hauptstadt das erste große Halloween
seitdem die corona-regeln gelockert
wurden
was dann folgt sind Bilder die schwer zu
ertragen sind während sie auf der Straße
versuchen Menschenleben zu retten geht
darin die Party weiter viele hatten gar
nicht mitbekommen was los war in einer
engen Seitenstraße war es so voll dass
viele der mehr als 150 Opfer erdrückt
oder niedergetrampelt wurden vor allem
junge Frauen
wie genau es zu der Massenpanik kam ist
noch unklar klar ist das Viertel war auf
den Ansturm nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet die Rettungskräfte kamen
nicht durch die vollgestopften Straßen
der südkoreanische Präsident kündigte
eine mehrtägige Staatstrauer an er wolle
sicherstellen dass so etwas nie wieder
passiert
jetzt so Innenpolitik die geplante
Einführung des Bürgergeldes ist das
große Prestigeprojekt der Kanzlerpartei
SPD jetzt droht die CDU die Umsetzung zu
torpedieren sollte die Ampel nicht
Zugeständnissen bereit sein über den
Plan der Hartz IV ersetzen soll und die
Kritik der CDU daran Ihnen
hier im Bundesrat ist die Ampel auf die
Stimmen der Unionsländer angewiesen will
sie das neue Bürgergeld durchsetzen doch
die Union droht mit Blockade
insbesondere stört Sie dass man auch mit
einem Vermögen von 150.000 Euro
Bürgergeld beziehen könnte dass man so
hohes Schonvermögen geschaffen hat von
150.000 Euro für eine vierköpfige
Familie das ist ungerecht und negative
Solidarität gegen gegenüber die das mit
eigenen Hände Arbeit erwirtschaften ein
deutlich höheres Schonvermögen höhere
Regelsätze weniger Sanktionen für die
Bezieher als bei Hartz IV so soll das
Bürgergeld aussehen dass die SPD heute
verteidigt das ist die größte
Sozialreform seit Jahren das wird helfen
auch in Weiterbildung
Qualifizierungsmaßnahmen für Menschen
die seit langer Zeit nicht in
Beschäftigung sind das gibt Sicherheit
in der Krise und wir wollen dass das zum
ersten Januar startet und dafür werden
wir jetzt kämpfen doch auch aus
praktischen Gründen könnte sich der
geplante Staat zum Jahresbeginn
verzögern Landkreise und Jobcenter
warnen der administrative Aufwand sei
groß eine Verschiebung des Bürgergelds
sinnvoll es kommt nach meiner festen
Überzeugung etwas zur umzeit der erste
januar steht vor der Tür die Jobcenter
sind hoch belastet wir haben jetzt die
Energiekrise wir haben die Ukraine
Flüchtlinge es ist eh wenig Zeit für
Integrationsmaßnahmen der Bundestag wird
sich nächste Woche abschließend mit dem
Bürgergeld befassen danach ist der
Bundesrat am Zug
und wir blicken nach Südamerika wo in
Brasilien heute die Stichwahl um das
Präsidentenamt stattfindet mehr als 150
Millionen Wahlberechtigte können
entscheiden wer das fünftgrößte Land der
Erde in Zukunft führen wird weiterhin
der rechtsextreme Amtsinhaber ja hier
bolsonaro oder aber sein linker
Herausforderer Lula das Silva der
Ausgang der Wahl dürfte nicht nur für
das zutiefst gespaltene Land
richtungsweisen sein und in Rio ist
Christoph rückerath für uns in einem
Wahllokal Christoph ein sehr enges
Rennen was bedeutet diese Ausgangslage
für Brasilien
das bedeutet zum einen für den Gewinner
der Wahl dass wir vor der schwierigen
Aufgabe steht dieses auch emotional sehr
aufgewühlte Land zu beruhigen und zu
allen Dingen es hat aber auch ganz
konkrete Auswirkungen auf den Wahltag
heute hier dürfen einer gewissen
Nervosität begleitet ist in knapp zwei
Stunden machen hier die Wahllokale zu
und in den letzten Stunden gab es immer
mehr übereinstimmende Meldungen dass
mutmaßlich mit Präsident bolzenario
Verbündete Polizeieinheiten im ganzen
Land vor allem in den Regionen die laut
Umfragen wahrscheinlich einen
Herausforderer Lula gehen dürften Busse
aufgehalten haben mit Wählern und am
wählen gehindert haben sollen mit
willkürlichen Straßensperren wir können
das nicht unabhängig bestätigen aber der
Oberste Gerichtshof hat sich
eingeschaltet und den Chef der
bundesstraßenpolizei einberufen um diese
Aktionen sofort zu unterbinden sollte es
sich hier manche befürchten hier meine
konzertierte Aktion handeln kann das
natürlich bei so einem knappen Rennen
das Wahlergebnis durchaus beeinflussen
zugunsten mutmaßliches Amtsinhabers das
wissen wir aber noch nicht es wäre ein
Eingriff in demokratischen Prozess
sicher ist das Ergebnis wird kommen
wahrscheinlich am späten brasilianischer
Zeit da müssen wir mehr vielen Dank nach
Rio Christoph röckerath
im Kampf gegen den weltweiten Hunger
galt das getreideabkommen zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine als großer
Erfolg bis gestern Moskau kündigte die
Abmachung auf und gibt der Ukraine die
Schuld US-Präsident beiden kritisiert
Russlands Rückzug als ungeheuerlich und
auch die EU warnt vor Hungersnöten Maike
Verlad violand
Frachtschiffe mit ukrainischem Getreide
bereits heute passierte keines von ihnen
mehr den Korridor im Schwarzen Meer der
Grund Russland beschuldigt die Ukraine
mit Drohnen die Schwarzmeerflotte in der
Stadt sevast topball angegriffen zu
haben die Ukraine wertet das einmal mehr
als Vorwand
eine starke internationale Antwort von
den Vereinten Nationen aber auch von
denen G20 von den Vereinten Nationen
hieß es man stehe bereits mit Russland
in Kontakt um die getreideausfuhr
weiterhin zu ermöglichen die Zeit drängt
für viele Menschen ist das Abkommen
überlebenswichtig vor dem Krieg waren
die größten Abnehmerländer von
ukrainischem Weizen Ägypten Indonesien
und Bangladesch
werden die Schiffe aus der Ukraine
blockiert steigen die Preise laut UN
hungern bereits jetzt etwa 50 Millionen
Menschen mehr in Folge des
ukrainekrieges
die türkische stämmige
Friedensbotschafterin mevlude genschis
im Alter von 79 Jahren gestorben
1993 hatte sie fünf ihrer
Familienmitglieder bei dem
rechtsextremistischen Brandanschlag in
Solingen verloren dennoch rief Genf
schon kurz nach der Tat zu Versöhnung
und Toleranz auf für Engagement erhielt
sie das Bundesverdienstkreuz
in Magdeburg hat Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier die höchst
deutsche Umwelt Auszeichnung verliehen
Friedrich Mewes und Dirk Lehmann haben
den Preis für eine von ihnen entwickelte
schiffsdüse erhalten sie senkt den
schwerölverbrauch bei Schiffen um bis zu
zehn Prozent 13 Millionen Tonnen CO2 hat
das bislang eingespart
Biologe Christoph Schenk bekam die
Auszeichnung für seinen Einsatz zum
Erhalt der tropischen Regenwälder
wir sind jetzt beim sonntagsport und
Christian genau los geht's mit Schwimmen
beim kurzbaren Weltcup im kanadischen
Toronto präsentiert sich Anna Elend in
starker Form sie schwamm über 100 Meter
Brust deutschen Rekord und dann gab es
bei den Frauen noch einen
beeindruckenden Weltrekord im längsten
Rennen
das Katie LED deckchy Weltrekord
schwimmt war wenig überraschend die Zeit
aber ist eine echte Machtdemonstration
die US-Amerikanerin unterbietet die
bisherige Bestmarke der deutschen
sarawelbrock um satte 10 Sekunden
dominiert das Rennen von Beginn an und
schlägt bei ihrem ersten 1500 Meter
freistehstart auf der Kurzbahn nach 15
Minuten 8 Sekunden und 2400 sind an für
das Highlight aus deutscher Sicht sorgt
Anna Elend auf Bahn 4 über 100 Meter
Brust wird die 21-Jährige in einem stark
besetzten Finale dritte und verbessert
ihren eigenen deutschen Rekord auf eine
Minute 04.07
und zum Fußball die Frauen des FC Bayern
München bleiben dran am
bundesliga-spitzen Duo aus Wolfsburg und
Frankfurt nach einer torlosen ersten
Halbzeit gegen den SV Meppen brachte
Nationalspielerin Clara Bühl in der 71
Minute die Gastgeberin in die
Erfolgsspur am Ende hieß es drei zu eins
bei den Männern beschließt Union Berlin
auch den zwölften Spieltag als
Tabellenführer mit einem Punkt Vorsprung
auf die Bayern die eisernen drehten eine
0:1 Rückstand gegen Borussia
Mönchengladbach in einen 2:1 Sieg und in
der Premier League hat der FC Arsenal
seine Spitzenposition eindrucksvoll
verteidigt die ganas verbuchten gegen
Nottingham Forest einen überragenden
Erfolg hier das 5:0 durch Kapitän Martin
ödegart der zehnte Triumph im 12 Spiel
zwei Punkte Vorsprung auf Verfolger
Manchester City das ist der
Titelverteidiger dann vielen Dank
Kristin und wir werfen noch schnell den
Blick aufs Wetter es gibt eine Mischung
aus dichten Wolken und sonnigen
Abschnitten
örtlich kann sich auch ca Nebel halten
dabei weitgehend trocken Höchstwerte
zwischen 15 und 21 Grad
ich empfehle das heute journal mit Anne
gallinek um 21 Uhr 45 so viel von uns
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen und jetzt
direkt weiter in die Hauptstadt zu
Berlin direkt und Theo Koll